Roald Dahl is one of the greatest children's
authors of all time — and plenty of movies have
been made from his books. But which adaptations
are worth a watch, and which are you better
off skipping? From worst to best, these are
Rotten Tomatoes' rankings of Roald Dahl movies.
So here's a fun fact for you: Quentin Tarantino
and Robert Rodriguez made a Roald Dahl movie —
which sounds like it could be either the greatest
or worst thing in the world. And, well, turns out
it was the worst. Before Tarantino and Rodriguez
teamed up for the anthology film Grindhouse, they
were two of the four directors who participated
in another anthology film: Four Rooms.
Loosely based on the adult short fiction works of
Dahl, Four Rooms is about the myriad misadventures
happening at a Hollywood hotel, with four separate
segments tied together by the new bellhop,
played by Tim Roth. While none of the directors'
four individual segments are particularly great,
Tarantino's is generally considered passable,
though not quite enough to pass muster with
critics. Four Rooms received a 13% critics' score
and a 69% audience score on Rotten Tomatoes,
making it the worst movie on Tarantino's and
Rodriguez's filmographies — as well as Dahl's.
The Witches was first adapted
to the big screen in 1990,
and then again 30 years later in 2020.
Well, not technically the big screen,
as The Witches actually debuted as an HBO Max
original. Set in 1967, the film finds a young
orphan boy and his grandmother running across
a convention of witches at a seaside hotel,
which is led by the world's Grand High Witch
— who, put simply, isn't a very nice woman.
"I will reach into your chest and rip
out your withered, shrivelled heart."
Unfortunately, despite a wealth of
talent in front of and behind the camera,
The Witches crash-lands on its flying
broomstick. As one critic put it:
"Like far too many unnecessary remakes,
The Witches doesn't do enough
to justify its existence."
And while The Witches might've
been meant for movie theaters,
the results were mediocre whatever the medium.
Actually, make that downright rotten — with 51%
from critics and 42% from audiences
on Rotten Tomatoes. All in all,
it's not hard to imagine that Dahl would want
nothing to do with this particular misfire.
Danny, the Champion of the World is a less
well-known Roald Dahl novel released in 1975,
that also inspired a mostly unseen TV movie in
1989. The movie adaptation pairs Jeremy Irons
with his son, Samuel Irons, who plays the titular
Danny. Together, the two star as a widowed father
and son who concoct a plan to get revenge on a
snobby property developer. Danny, the Champion
of the World isn't especially memorable,
though it did inspire one critic to say that:
"[It] resurrects a lost world of English life
and entertainment with winning charm and aplomb."
"One" being the operative word there, because
Rotten Tomatoes only has a single review for
this movie on its site. As such, Danny, the
Champion of the World has no critics' score,
however, its audience score
is an underwhelming 64%.
Maybe if more people saw it, the score
would be higher, but as it stands,
Danny may be the champion of the world — but
he's not the champion of the Tomatometer.
Released in 1982, Roahl Dahl's The BFG
is about a big, friendly giant — the
clue's in the name — who befriends a
precocious little girl named Sophie.
Dahl's story was first adapted to the screen in
1989 as an animated feature. You'll be forgiven if
you haven't seen it or even heard of it, though,
because pretty much nobody else has. The BFG only
has two critical reviews, so it doesn't even have
an official Tomatometer score, though one critic
praised it as a, quote, "giant tale of imagination
with a dark side," while another panned it as,
quote, "slight and unimpressive." So let's
call it a wash. The audience score is an
equally underwhelming 65% — which is still fresh,
but nothing to write home about! While The BFG
would later go on to bigger and better things, the
1989 animated film was, alas, a big freaking dud.
Esio Trot was Roald Dahl's last published
novel, and it's just the kind of love story
you would expect Dahl to write — revolving
around a lonely old man named Mr. Hoppy,
a widow named Mrs. Silver,
and her pet tortoise, Alfie.
Esio Trot was adapted into a BBC television film
in 2015, with Dustin Hoffman as Mr. Hoppy, Judi
Dench as Mrs. Silver, and James Corden narrating.
This charming adaptation received plenty of
critical acclaim, but it wasn't widely seen across
the pond. Consequently, Esio Trot doesn't have
an official critics' score on Rotten Tomatoes,
though the one critic who reviewed it said it was:
"A decidedly daffy, rather ridiculously
resplendent reptilian elder romance. Don't ask."
Those who did see it quite enjoyed it too, giving
the movie a respectable audience score of 72%.
Steven Spielberg decided to take on The BFG
in 2016 under the Disney banner. Spielberg,
Dahl, and Disney. Sounds like
the perfect combo, right? Sadly,
the result of this historic pairing was... just
kind of okay. The critical consensus was that:
"The BFG minimizes the darker elements
of Roald Dahl's classic in favor of a
resolutely good-natured, visually stunning, and
largely successful family-friendly adventure."
In other words, it's Disney at its safest. Other
critics were more critical, with one writing:
"Spielberg has become a hit-and-miss filmmaker,
and this is closer to a 'miss' than a 'hit.'"
The critics' Tomatometer
score is currently at 74%,
while audiences were much less impressed,
giving it a 57%. Who would've thought the
combined creative might of Spielberg, Dahl, and
Disney could produce something so darn mediocre?
Roald Dahl cemented his icon
status by writing children's books,
but he made his living by writing just
about everything. And among Dahl's more
interesting works is the 1965
suspense thriller 36 Hours,
which holds the distinction of having been
the first ever film adaptation of his writing.
Set in occupied Germany in 1949, James Garner
plays an amnesiac American military officer
whose last memories were General
Eisenhower's final directives before
the Normandy invasion five years earlier.
But soon, the American officer realizes
the psychiatrist he thought was trying
to help him is actually out to get him.
36 Hours is based on a 1944 Dahl short
story called "Beware of the Dog," which
ably demonstrates just how different
Dahl was during the war — after all,
the man was a spy and a fighter
pilot. The results are impressive too,
on both the page and the big screen, as
36 Hours boasts an 80% critic's score
and a 77% audience score, marking the movie as
the best adaptation of Dahl's adult fiction.
Johnny Depp really could do no wrong in the
mid-2000s. He had just redefined himself from
quirky indie darling actor to quirky A-lister
by starring in Pirates of the Caribbean:
Curse of the Black Pearl. And a year before
the sequel, Dead Man's Chest, came out,
Depp took a detour to Dahl. In 2005, he reunited
with his buddy Tim Burton to play Willy Wonka
in arguably Roald Dahl's most famous
story, Charlie and the Chocolate Factory.
While it may have seemed counterintuitive at the
time, Burton's cinematic sensibilities toward the
creepy and the spooky were actually the perfect
fit for Roald Dahl's work, which always managed to
blend the surreal and scary with the silly. And at
the time, you weren't going to get a better actor
to play the world-famous but notoriously
reclusive chocolatier than Johnny Depp.
"I'm Augustus Gloop. I love your chocolate."
"I can see that. So do I. I never
expected to have so much in common."
The team had their work cut out for them, however,
as whatever they made would inevitably be compared
to the iconic 1971 film, Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory. Luckily, Burton, Depp and team
were up to the task, as Charlie and Chocolate
Factory scored an 83% critics' score — though
moviegoer's didn't find the film nearly so
sweet, giving it a disappointingly rotten 51%.
Danny DeVito is a genuine national
treasure — but you already know that,
don't you? Before he reinvented himself as Frank
Reynolds on It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia,
DeVito was actually an acclaimed actor and
filmmaker — and among his most famous films
was his 1996 adaptation of Roald
Dahl's Matilda. Released in 1988,
Matilda is arguably Roald Dahl's last great
work. It tells the story of a young girl named
Matilda Wormwood who has wicked parents, a cruel
headmistress, and some extraordinary powers.
DeVito cast himself and his then-wife Rhea Perlman
as Matilda's parents, while Mara Wilson of Mrs.
Doubtfire and Miracle on 34th Street fame earned
the role of the eponymous Matilda. Critics noted:
"While the movie diverges from Roald Dahl,
it nonetheless captures the book's spirit."
Matilda also captured an
impressive Tomatometer score,
too — 90% from critics and 73% from moviegoers.
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory is arguably
the most iconic Roald Dahl movie adaption.
Heck, it's one of the most beloved
family movies of all time, period,
and the movie has charmed viewers of
all ages since it was released in 1971.
Surprisingly, however, one viewer
who wasn't charmed was Roald Dahl.
According to a biography of the
author by his friend Donald Sturrock,
Dahl didn't much care for the music
or the director, and had, quote,
"serious reservations" with
Gene Wilder's performance as
the titular Willy Wonka — despite that same
performance having gone down in movie history.
"You get nothing! You lose! Good day, sir!"
According to Sturrock:
"Roald eventually came to tolerate the
film. [...] But he never liked it."
Dahl was mostly alone in his assessment
of Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory,
however, which boasts a 90% critics'
score and an 87% moviegoers' score.
It took decades for filmmakers to realize
Roald Dahl stories were perfect fodder for
stop-motion animation. Finally, however, 1996
saw the release of James and the Giant Peach,
by far one of the best Roald Dahl adaptations.
Nine years before Tim Burton directed Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory, he produced
James and the Giant Peach by employing
the same stop-motion techniques as the iconic
stop-motion film The Nightmare Before Christmas.
Helmed by Nightmare director Henry Selick,
James and the Giant Peach was praised by
critics, with Rotten Tomatoes' consensus reading:
"The arresting and dynamic
visuals, offbeat details
and light-as-air storytelling make James and
the Giant Peach solid family entertainment."
Critics gave the movie an
impressive 91% Tomatometer score,
though moviegoers were much less
impressed, with a decidedly unripened 66%
score. Moviegoers' apathy with James
and the Giant Peach was reflected in
the film's box office too, which bombed
hard with a meager $28 million worldwide.
When it comes to fantasy stories that
entertain children and adults alike,
few can match the talent of Roald Dahl. One
who certainly can, however, is Jim Henson,
creator of Sesame Street and The Muppets.
Dahl's talent for storytelling and Henson's
creative prowess as a producer came
together in 1990's The Witches,
and the results were nothing less than magical.
According to Rotten Tomatoes' consensus:
"The Witches is a dark and witty
movie [that] captures the spirit
of Roald Dahl's imagination
like few other adaptations."
Critics also praised Anjelica Huston's, quote,
"deliciously wicked performance" as the Grand
High Witch, as well as Jim Henson's typically
brilliant puppetry. All in all, everybody
was on top of their game with this one,
resulting in one of the most impressive and
faithful adaptations of Roald Dahl's work.
And it's got the Tomatometer score to prove it,
too, with 93% from critics and 70% from audiences.
Fantastic Mr. Fox is a movie truly worthy
of its name. Roald Dahl published the
anthropomorphic adventures of Mr. Fox, Mrs.
Fox, their family and their friends in 1970,
and in 2009, Wes Anderson adapted the story for
his first venture into stop-motion animation.
While Fantastic Mr. Fox's brisk 96 pages
are as delightfully Dahl as it gets,
the story isn't quite his best-known.
Nonetheless, the quirky whimsy of Dahl's
lesser-appreciated story matches perfectly
with Anderson's cinematic sensibilities.
"By the way, you look unbelievably
beautiful tonight. You're practically
glowing. Maybe it's the light."
While the two acclaimed artists never met,
Anderson clearly shares a creative kinship
with Dahl, and both managed to cultivate
a similar sense of childlike spirit in
their works — and that spirit comes together
perfectly with Mr. Fox. Critics seem to agree,
too, and with a 93% critics'
score and 85% audience score,
Fantastic Mr. Fox ranks as the
finest Roald Dahl adaptation to date.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.